welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division has us wondering
that
someone else must be coming and for many
that someone is
ultron the marvel villain whose age
lasted
just about a few hours yet a character
whose dna
has lived on in vision and who was
finally name-dropped and won a vision to
keep him from fading into the afterlife
according to coco law
he was killed by ultron
peace in our time and now that the
intricacies of vision's anatomical
structure are front and center
no i'm not talking about that suggestive
still frame you keep tweeting at me we
all know it's really purple
ultron's return seems more possible now
than ever
so i'm gonna explain how this ultron
avengers rematch could work
spoiler warning in case i am right on
this theory so in the past when folks
have asked me about ultron's return in
one division i've been
hesitant mostly because that question
usually comes in the form of someone
tweeting at me a screen grab of google
search results
showing that james spader is confirmed
to be in the one of vision cast
just a reminder folks google search
results are
not a verified news source google is not
a source it's an aggregator of various
sources
some of them legit news some of them
just random blogs
and if just enough people post something
say speculation that
ultron might be in one division or that
toby mcguire might be in spiderman no
way home or hugh jackman could be an
avengers in game
it could totally show up on google or
even imdb or wikipedia as was the case
with that hugh jackman adventures
in-game thing so i beg of you before you
re-share something out in the world just
spend five
seconds fact-checking it with a
legitimate news source and until you do
that trust
nothing you see on social media
including youtubers
but hey no shame and imagination right i
get the momentum of this theory i want
ultron back too
i've made several videos on this channel
theorizing exactly how ultron could
return including all the way back in
october 2019
like two or three blue dungeons ago back
in the age of masklessness
my theory then just needed one final
puzzle piece to get ultron back in the
game
and now i think i found that last solid
clue see the last time we saw ultron he
was debating the merits of humanity with
vision after the battle of sokovia
vision and the rest of the avengers had
cleared all the ultron sentries from the
city leaving no
other drones for ultron's consciousness
to jump into and escape into the world
aside from this last broken one which
was actually the same century cat busted
up with his shield
and threw off the bridge earlier in the
battle vision seemed to finish off
voltron
by blasting him with the mind stone but
notice the camera cuts away to a
distance so we don't really see how
exactly that final sentry gets destroyed
then years later peter parker pulled a
severed ultron sentry head from a bag of
scraps in the dodc storage with its eyes
glowing red which is how we knew which
century possessed ultron's consciousness
in any given moment probably a joke in
spider-man homecoming but it was seen as
a sign too many that ultron's ai may be
floating around
somewhere in the mcu now remember during
the battle of sekovia one ultron sentry
crashed into nick fury's helicarrier
which
might have given it enough time to
connect with one of fury's computers and
leave a trace of ultron's code there
but going back to that death moment
since we didn't see exactly what vision
did to ultron and those trees my theory
was that in order to permanently ensure
that
ultron's virus could be contained
incapable of spreading to any other
piece of technology on the world that
vision might have absorbed ultron's os
the way ultron had
previously absorbed jarvis now trapping
ultron as a prisoner
inside vision's head and that visions
occasional dark flashes over the years
since then
from trapping wanda in the avengers
compound to misfiring at boom you're
looking for roadie we're really
ultron's consciousness briefly surfacing
before getting
buried back into vision's digital sunken
place now in one division the vision in
west view was a creation of wanda's
chaos magic which since she's a nexus
being capable of spontaneous reality
manifestation
includes visions vibranium flesh and the
mind stone in his head
at least as long as he's still in the
hex but this vision does not possess
any memory of ultron until darcy fills
him in but
white vision created by hayward from
vision's actual damaged parts in the
real world is made up of whatever
hardware was left over from vision's mcu
history from ultron to thanos
revealed in the episode 8 post credits
scene that white vision was just about
to launch
setting up a white vision vs scarlet
vision battle in the finale though as
of that moment we have not heard white
vision talk yet so many speculated that
he might have the voice of james spader
ultron but my problem with that was that
it might feel like a bit of a goofy
misuse of james spader's talent just to
have his voice come out of paul
bettany's mouth i also doubt most
viewers would even recognize spader's
voice right away
not to mention the millions of viewers
watching wanda vision with international
dubbing like some german watcher would
be like yes they use the same voice of a
guy who did ultron and age of ultron
i know who's that is i'm sorry they need
germans out there you don't sound like
that but uh before i continue thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugars and zero
artificial colors
each 16 ounce can contains 300
milligrams of caffeine
coq10 and bcaas i'm sipping on pina
colada
that nice tropical flavor that just
takes you to your happy place
but gives you the energy to fight off
any unwelcome tourist dude show me too
much skin put your shirt on
i typically pop up in a bang when i need
to pick me up in the morning or when i
need to plow through a long video
and want my mind to be alert check out
bang on instagram get 10
off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars 10. there
you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or grab a 12 pack of citrus twist
bankster berry or the new delish
strawberry kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 to receive
10 off your bang energy order that's
code newark starts 10 for 10
off
but here's the deal folks this show has
been very clear about the rules of
wanda's hex border well
kind of clear anything that breaches
this wall from the outside
warps into something contemporarily
appropriate to wanda's current
sitcom era that's how monica got the
idea to send in an 80s era stark drone
so that it wouldn't warp in the 80s
reality it would just blend in
a military drone blending in with a
residential neighborhood don't question
everything
now we could say white vision is a
superpowered exception the way monica
later was
but monica seems to be a unique case
immune to radiation on that third pass
due to the specific nature of her
physiology
white vision made up of the mcu vision's
corpse parts
is a modern creation frankenstein in the
year 2023 in the outside world
so he must take on a new form when he
enters the hex
and in the episode 8 breakdown i pointed
out that you can see the year 2013
behind the stage lights
at first i thought this was a throwaway
detail establishing wanda's latest
modern family warp just as the year 2013
10 years earlier but now i think this
must have been specific
why would you add this westview needs
its final era to be 10 years
earlier than the outside world to set up
that when white vision enters that hex
he warps into the form he was in that
past decade
around the years of 2013 to 2015 the
previous vibranium model 2 vision
before the mind stone was plugged in
ultron that might be why it was so
important for that drone to be a stark
industries one
ultron was a product of stark tech when
white vision looks down at his hands
upon awakening you can almost imagine
hearing the voice of james spader saying
there are no strings on me and you can
definitely imagine wanda feeling
especially hungry to
permanently kill the monster who killed
pietro white vision
warping into ultron as he enters the
westview arena
is how we get the avengers ultron
rematch we've been wanting
but keeping it within the confines of
the hex reality now
ultron probably is not the cameo paul
bettany teased since betany already had
scenes with james spader in age of
ultron but it's also very possible that
betany was just trolling us by saying
the big cameo of an actor he always
wanted to work with that he had
fireworks with
israeli himself who knows what the [ __ ]
i was talking about hey if you haven't
already this is our an unusual couple
shirt a shirt which
along with its purple counterpart are
about to sell out it's your last chance
to get these you just got to go to
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for everything wandavision
thank you for watching bye
matt was dramatic
[Music]
you